Speaker 1: . All right, let's get into
your emails, the e-mail bag, so to speak,
it's really more of a folder. But, you know,
I think the imagery of the mailbag is still
maybe relevant in modern society. In twenty
twenty one info at David Pakman, Dotcom is
the place to email. Let's see what's on
some people's minds. First, many responses
to my response to making manages tweet about her
cousin's friend's testicle swelling. You guys
remember this story? Phil wrote to me and said
Technical responds to swollen apple bags. Hey,
David just watched your episode and thought you
might want to read through this. Yes, of course,
it can occur with Estes's, but it can also
occur via covid itself, apparently, or mumps.
I'm vaccinated and had a breakthrough case along
with my girlfriend a couple of weeks ago and was
panicking when I noticed a bit of inflammation
on myself after extensive Googling because I
currently don't have health insurance through my
employer. I live in Texas. Big surprise, right?
I came across a few articles like this. Just
wanted to send it your way, since it seems more
likely to me that Nicki Minaj is cousins brother's
dog sitter, twice removed, probably just got
exposed to covid after getting the vaccine,
then getting it from the vaccine or an STI,
even although that's obviously statistically more
likely than getting it from the vaccine. Yeah,
it's the Ministry of Health from Trinidad and
Tobago said we found no reporting at all about
this case of the swollen testicles from the
vaccine. And I think if it is even at all real,
which we don't know, but if it's a real story,
if Nicki Minaj is cousin's friend's testicles,
really did swell, it would almost certainly be
from something else. Could be covered itself.
Could be. Or Chitose from gonorrhea.
Chlamydia, you know something else.
Also, an email about Tucker Carlson's interest in
the swollen testicles of Nicki Minaj. His cousin's
friend, JFK, wrote in and said Tucker Carlson's
rant over someone else's balls has a different
problem. How many men have experienced erection
issues under stress? Every man has. At some point,
the guy's fiancee calls off the wedding because
he's dysfunctional better than he found out. Now,
she didn't really love him. Let's take this
to the bizarre far right Bible thumping side.
Why is she having sex before marriage? There is
far more evidence that sars-cov-2 can and does
cause capillary dysfunction in male testicles.
Yeah, that's another story that was brought to
light accurately, which is covid itself seems
to carry a risk of sexual dysfunction. But I
keep going back that it is weird that because
of a vaccine, a supposed vaccine reaction,
Nicki Minaj is cousin's friend's fiancee, called
off the wedding. It's like, well, if it's just a
medical issue, reacting to the vaccine, wouldn't
wouldn't you just get married anywhere? It's all
very, very strange. Next email is from Brendan.
Brendan writes in about the Novavax vaccine, says,
Hey, David, I believe we'll see vaccination
rates go up in this country about 20 percent
if the Novavax vaccine ends up becoming available
in the U.S., many covid vaccine, hesitant people
who are currently unvaccinated are holding out
for the Novavax as it's subunit protein technology
makes it closer to traditional influenza vaccines.
It also has greater than 90 percent efficacy from
trials and has been touted as likely the
best vaccine yet, even by publications like
The Atlantic. Have you read up on it? I have, but
not recently enough to know whether these claims
are still accurate, Brendan says. Anyway, I think
the vaccine issue, this is a vaccine issue worth
discussing. I am open to and interested in any
efficacious and safe vaccine being put forward
with the goal of it. Working for someone who's
not yet been vaccinated, I hesitate to put too
much stock in any people still not vaccinated,
claiming I'll get vaccinated as soon as X,
because for the most part there's been a lot
of B.S. Look at all the people who said I'd get
vaccinated as soon as the vaccine is FDA approved.
The numbers have barely trickled up since
the vaccine was FDA approved weeks ago. Many of
them have moved on to something else, including
saying the approval is untrustworthy because it
was political or whatever the case may be. So I am
really skeptical about any one thing having
that much of an impact except the airfare,
the air aviation thing. I do think that while it
won't be the forty one percent of anti vax people
who claimed they would get vaccinated, if you need
one to fly, I don't think forty one percent will
actually go and do it. I do. Every belief
that if a vaccine was required to fly.
A lot of anti vax people would go and get
vaccinated, so Novavax airline requirement,
employee requirement, let's try everything to
try to get those numbers. Up next, email is from
Randall Randall wrote in about the January 5th,
January 6th pipe bomb surveillance video. These
are the pipe bombs placed in D.C. on January 5th,
found on January 6th in and around the time that
the Trump riots were going on. Randol says, David,
I believe that you and your friends are correct
about the suspect being a woman. As you watch
the suspect, as they sit down on the bench,
they place their knees together. How many men do
that? Definitely a woman. I actually didn't notice
that, and I don't know much about that. I've never
really paid attention to placing these together.
When I sit down, yeah, I guess I don't I don't
put my knees together, but that's just me.
I don't know if this is some kind of gender
stereotype, if there's any basis in science was I
really have no idea. I've also not heard anything
additional about the identity of the pipe bomb
suspect. And it is so difficult for me to believe
that nobody knows a thing about it. It's just
really, really difficult to imagine that that's
the case. Hopefully we will know something soon.
And yeah, I got a lot of emails after the segment
last week from people saying, I agree with you,
David. I do think that the suspect is a woman.
That may have been because I mentioned it. I
don't I really don't know. I have no idea. But if
you know anything, please, please, please contact
the FBI. Very, very important stuff. Next email is
from Paul. Paul writes to me, the only legitimate
anti vax argument, so I thought this should
be good. Let's see what Paul says. Dear David,
while most of the arguments I've heard from the
anti vaccines are based on conspiracy theories
or simply scientifically inaccurate. There is
one legitimate reason for vaccine hesitancy
that I can't argue against. We don't know the
long term effects of these vaccines. We don't know
that five to ten years from now, vaccinated
individuals won't be dropping dead of heart
attacks. What do you say to people who have
these fears and what makes you so confident
you won't develop long term side effects? Cheers,
Paul. This is not a new argument. OK, there is
this is an indefeasible argument because you can
always argue however long the vaccine's been out,
we don't yet know that some kind of side effect
doesn't start right after that. The polio vaccine,
it's been out 70 years. How do we know that on
year seventy one, the polio vaccine doesn't cause
some kind of problem? It's and the problem with
this argument is it's indefeasible. You can't
defeat this argument because you could always say,
well, the vaccines been out 11 years. The problems
might start after 12 years. So my feeling on this
is based on speaking to doctors and virologists
and epidemiologists about how the vaccine works
and how the substance of the vaccine clears from
your body relatively quickly. I have no reason to
believe. That there is some magical period of time
after which there will be some
new problem in addition to that,
with the with a very narrow exception about GB's
Johnsbury syndrome, which we've talked about
and which is now better understood, there aren't
examples of what this person is saying either. So
it's not about why am I personally so confident I
won't have a long term side effect in five years
and 10 years, whatever, from the vaccine,
the decades long research on MRI technology
and now the century of vaccination century plus
actually, if you include, you know, smallpox
tells us that that does not seem to be how vaccine
works. And so that's why I've made the decision
to go and get vaccinated. But this is the type
of argument that you can never defeat because
they could always say, listen, if OK, the vaccine
causes no side effects for 100 years, if lifespans
increase, we don't know what that vaccine could
do. You can always make that argument. It really
gets us nowhere. It's not supported by evidence.
OK, and then Kurt wrote to me, Kurt wrote to me
about rules during the pandemic. Kurt says an
old newspaper article from 1918 showing a list
of do's and don'ts for preventing the Spanish flu
looks painfully familiar. My favorite is this one
quote, Do not disregard the advice of a specialist
just because you do not understand. Yeah, I mean,
it's it's sort of depressing in a sense that.
We have all these new medical technologies
and a vaccine were developed, we have all these
new treatments and we have, you know, ECMO
machines and ventilators and all these different
things. But to just stop the spread, it's hygiene,
it's physical distance and it's masking. That's
basically what it is. This really hasn't changed.
And yet still, we have so many people who either
don't understand it or refuse to do it or think
they know better than the experts or believe the
experts are part of some conspiracy. There's a lot
of stuff. And we interviewed an author who who
is an historian, a historian and historian of
the 1918 flu. And he told us about
a lot of the same dynamics, science,
skeptical people, people refusing to participate
in the guidelines, et cetera. One hundred years
ago, I mean, one hundred and three years ago,
at this point in time, some things never change,
seemingly, or at least they take a really long
time to change. Send me your emails. Maybe they
will be picked and featured on next week's e-mail
bag info at David Pakman Dotcom. We've got a great
bonus show coming up for you today. You can
sign up at join Pakman dot com, please sign
up. It really is a great revenue source for us and
makes us independent of big media and advertisers
because it's just you guys. You guys control the
show, you fund the show, you can sign up at join
Pakman Dotcom and use the coupon code better.
Twenty one. We'll see you on the bonus show. If
you're not so inclined, then we will talk
Unidentified: to you on Monday.